hey everybody what is going on as you
can tell by the title of this video yet
another tamron lens i'm telling you this
is tamron lens month man we have the
2875 g2 the 35 150 f2 to 2.8 and now the
18 to 300 f 3.5 to 6.3
v c v x d lens how did i memorize that i
have no idea for the fujifilm x mode
tamron you could you can bring down the
name of the lens a little bit nobody's
going to remember all that except us for
viewers anyway like all the reviews
we're not paid or sponsored unless we
tell you guys but big thanks to tamron
singapore for providing the lens for
this review but it does go right back to
them right after this recording so with
that let's talk about the all new tamron
18 to 300 lens as the title suggests i
am talking about the fujifilm x-mount
version of this lens yes there is a sony
e-mount version but we have done a lot
of sony lenses as of late and i felt
that it's more fair to review this for
the fujifilm x-mount users out there
because this is the first time as i
remember it we're seeing a large
third-party manufacturer actually make
an autofocus lens for the fujifilm
x-mount now i know there's manual focus
lenses out there tt artists and seven
artisans and a variety of other
companies but i don't remember seeing
a third-party lens like tamron or like
sigma coming out with an autofocus lens
for the fujifilm x mount as of yet but i
think sigma may be doing it in the
future that's what i'm hearing on the
rumor mill anyway let's talk about this
bad boy real quick here 18 to 300 that
is a wide vocal range that's equivalent
to 27 millimeters to 450 millimeters for
your full-frame folks out there but this
is going to cover pretty much anything
you want to shoot minus
you know
like bird photography where you're going
to need like six or eight hundred
millimeters or wildlife photographer for
your sports but for the majority of
people out there 18 to 300
is got you covered now you do have a
slower aperture on this lens that have
3.5 to 6.3 which i will talk about in
just a bit because that to me is one of
the downsides of this lens but you got
to give tamron credit for really pushing
the boundaries in terms of the focal
range right now this is a telescopic
zoom lens it's not an internal zoom i
don't know if you could do an internal
zoom lens from 18 to 300 folks that
would be a massive size lens this is
already you know decent in weight coming
into 620 grams but you know because it
does have a slower aperture and doesn't
have so much glass inside of that thing
to you know give you those amazing
optics as you would get on a faster
aperture lens
you know the size is pretty compact
especially for a fujifilm camera or a
sony a series camera for that matter now
this kit lens also does have vc or
vibration compensation inside of it so
this is tamron sort of optical
stabilization inside their lens now it's
not fantastic and it's not bad it's a
run-of-the-mill it will do the job but
it's not going to give you phenomenal
image stabilization in your lens okay
you're still going to be reliant on the
body now depending on the body that you
have for the fujifilm system you may
already have it let's say the xd4 for
that matter but if you're using the xs10
and things like that you're not going to
have it so you know this is something to
take in consideration when you're
looking to purchase this lens now you do
have 19 elements in 15 groups you also
have three hybrid spherical elements on
the side of this and low dispersion
elements i mean the mtf charts look
fantastic on this but i don't rely on
mtf charts i actually rely on real world
usage when i take images especially with
lenses such like this because
you know it all depends on your lighting
source it all depends on your iso
settings and as we know with fujifilm
systems when the iso creeps up in your
lower light situations it does struggle
a little bit in terms of image quality
you are going to lose a lot of that
resolution power and you're going to
notice that with this lens i'll talk
about that in just a bit as well but
overall i have to say that the build
quality this lens is very reminiscent of
previous tamron lenses we've seen on the
market it's not comparable to the g2
lens that i've talked about here uh the
2875 or the 35 150 which are the newer
tamron lenses this has the body
construction of the previous tamron
lenses so it's more plastic and feel um
it very non-descript
i would say when you put it on to let's
say the xt4 even the xs-10 for that
matter it doesn't necessarily match the
fujifilm design i would have been nice
if tamara would have done more of a
retro themed vibe for this but of course
they're basically using the same lens
and just changing them out on the back
of it from sony to fujifilm so in that
regard i understand why they did it but
it just doesn't match some of fujifilm's
own lens designs that they make for
their uh for their body so just
something to keep in um keep in mind i
mean
designs of lenses are very uh it's a
very personal preference on this some
people will love a nondescript and some
people want something that looks very
retro to each their own
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if p leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.com
now let's talk about another feature
that a lot of tamron users like and
that's like close focusing distance
right now this is also in this 18 to
300. now at its widest focal length
they're gonna get .15 meters close focus
again and it's the farthest focal length
you're going to get 0.99 meters still
going to get some great pseudo macro
capabilities with this lens and that's
pretty impressive for 18 to 300 so
tamron has really put a lot inside of
this but now we got to talk about
performance um and this is where i think
it's going to be a little bit uh
different depending on how you're going
to use this lens now i know taramon is
looking at this lens as to say the
all-in-one lens you know the one lens
you're going to take with you on a trip
you know it's gonna cover you from you
know landscape to
capturing people in the distance or
wildlife or some birds or maybe some
sports
you get all that into this lens
however as i mentioned earlier that
aperture is really going to take a toll
on you especially if you're not shooting
in bright light conditions case in point
i shot an overcast with uh you know
about 10 o'clock 11 a.m
with my dog in the dog park
and you know the images are not that
sharp the noise is creeping in it
doesn't you don't see that crispness
that you're used to seeing out of tamron
lenses and i think a lot of it's due to
the aperture on this you know shooting
at 300 it's 6.3 and that's
uh that's not that great um it would be
nice to you know top it out of 5.6 bit
6.3 you're really pushing the sensor and
even wide open at 18 millimeters you're
only at 3.5 for the first five
millimeters then you jump into you know
f4 after that but
you know it's something that um i would
say as a professional photographer you
may want to think twice about it looks
great on paper but in actual usability
it's a little bit uh trying also when it
comes to the uh the performance of this
lens in terms of the focusing it's got
the vxd motors in it so it should on
paper focus really quickly but i found
that in faster action situations that
this lens didn't quite nail focus as
much as i thought it would compared to
native fujifilm lenses it's not a deal
breaker but it's something that you will
need to take note of but of course if
you're shooting still subjects you're
not going to find an issue or see any
issue it's only when you're really
tracking and going fast action is you're
going to notice a bit of a difference
with this lens versus the native lenses
in that regard um the vibration
compensation inside of it is actually
okay is it's not class leading it's not
going to blow your mind it will
complement the body that you're using
but i would say that
from the previous lenses that i've used
from tamron in terms of the vibration
conversation i don't find it to be wow
but it's okay and i'm glad that it's
there i mean i'd rather have it than not
have it so and especially with an 18 to
300 you definitely want to have it at
your longest longest vocal range at 300
millimeters because that's when you're
going to get a lot of camera shake
you're going to get a lot of movement
and you don't want to lose a shot
because of a of a little blur because
the lens and the body just can't uh stay
steady so i'm glad that it's there in
that regard so now what i want to do is
i want to show you some sample images
that i've taken with this 18 to 300 on
the fujifilm xt4 and then i'll give you
my final thoughts after that so with
that enjoy the photos
[Applause]
[Music]
all right as you saw from the images i
mean pretty decent images i mean nothing
that's going to wow you but this lens is
not a wow lens this is a
quote-unquote workhorse hobbyist lens
all-round lens it's not going to be the
lens that's going to blow your mind with
a beautiful bokeh on it it's not going
to blow your mind with sharpness it's
just good overall as you saw in lower
light conditions you do lose a little
bit of sharpness even when the subject
is still
it's it's good enough for social media
and i think it'll be good enough for
most people out there but if you really
are a
you know one of those photographers that
really takes you know
you know that pixel peeps a bit and
really wants pin sharp images and you
wanted something that compares to some
of the newer optics coming from fujifilm
on their lenses you're gonna see that
this one doesn't quite match up to that
right now as i mentioned before great
hobbyist lens going on a trip don't want
to carry a lot of things in your bag
want to keep it nice and easy this is a
great lens to take with you just don't
shoot at night time because you may be a
little bit frustrated with the noise out
of it but if you're a professional i
would definitely try it out at a camera
shop or if you do have a return policy
on wherever you order from try it and
see how it works for you for me as a as
if i was a pro photographer using this i
probably would opt out of it i would
look for something with a faster
aperture but that is just my personal
taste everybody's different but those
are my thoughts on the terramont 18 to
f 3.5 to 6.3 d i a v c v x d lens let me
know your thoughts in the comments
section below any questions you have on
it let me hit me up on that and with
that guys follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video helps out our channel a lot take
care stay safe and i'll chat to you soon
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you